hello everyone while we're at the
subject I thought why not make another
video to finish the London chest classic
series so this is a game for from the
tiebreaks Fabiano Caruana vs. jana from
yashi first three games were drawn and
this is game number four before the I
mean after the game Khurana said in an
interview that his game against Michael
Adams lasted for six hours so he was
simply too tired to be nervous or
anything he just sat down and played so
let's see this game Corona has the white
pieces and he plays c4 c5 the Sicilian
defense Knight to f3 d6 and Bishop to b5
check the canal attack Bishop to d7 we
have a four Knight to c6 Corona
castles g6 c3 Knight to f6 and the d4
seek after Sundy for seek after sandy
four and the Bishop to g7 we have Knight
to c3
Napo castles h3 and a six
Bishop to c4 and rook to c8 and it's it
seems like there's this is a good time
to play Bishop to b2 b3 or maybe better
to since the rock aligned itself up with
the bishop but a roughly one by Caruana
there is no immediate way to take
advantage of this relationship so nipple
goes night to e8 and here definitely
there are some tricks on the board
Bishop to b3 by Caruana if Corona played
something like Queen d3 okay you are
protecting the bishop on c4 but then
neppo has the this Bishop captures on d4
and after Knight captures Knight to d5
now you're attacking both the Queen and
the bishop so Bishop captures on f7
would have to be played just to grab
back the pawn Rock characters and after
Queen to d1 it's a it's a good for it's
a good position for white but this is a
10 minute game so no reason to give an F
of activity of the pieces and open files
for the rooks
so after 98 Bishop to b3 by Caruana
Knight to a5 Bishop to e2 and now Knight
to c4 and Knight to c4 is a bit
over-optimistic Khurana takes advantage
of this swiftly Queen to d3 now with a
double attack on the night and here
neppo decides to play b5 which is
essentially given up a pawn but if you
play something like Knight to a5 then B
4 is coming 96 rugby 1 this pawn is
ready to be pushed to be 5 and this is a
whole lot of expansion for white very it
would be a very unpleasant position for
black
so after Queen d3 nepo decide to go for
b-58 capture say captures and b3 now
kicking away the night 95 and Knight
captures on b5 so Caruana grabs a pawn
Queen to b6 threatening the knight
Knight goes to a3 Knight to c6 and night
to see - so come on is up a pawn but
still it's hard to convert it so it's a
10 minute game night to c7 Bishop to e3
now threatening moves like d4 Queen to
b5 we have Queen to d2 b v e5 now now
blocking this dark square bishop it's
now now not a very good piece Bishop to
f5 and we have rook e to see 1/9 to e6
and night the e1 Bishop three four
Knights to h2 not allowing Bishop to
capture nights the be for rook captures
on c8 rook captures on c8 and now Bishop
to be one h5 not allowing any 94 to h6
ideas and night h2 f3 Knight to c6 and
Bishop - C - Bishop captures and c2
Queen captures on c2 and wrote the b8
now night to d3 and here we have Bishop
to f8 you can grab this pawn the night
will be hanging on c6 so after Bishop f8
rook to be one protecting the pawn
Knight to g7
night the c5 and now Knight to f5
attacking the bishop on e3 and we have e
6 and probably the best move would be
something like to push f6 but
937 and you have a monster outpost for
this night on d7 so would be very
unpleasant so after each six Bishop to
g7 was played we have he captures on f7
with check King captures and Knight to
d7 now attacking the rook and this is
the position nepo was going for he
played Knight see captures on d4 and we
have Knight d2 e5 check Bishop captures
and you have to capture this with the
bishop if you play something like King
to g8
then Bishop captures and after Knight
captures Knight captures you lose a
piece you can't capture the night
because your queen is hanging on b5 so
after this Knight d2 e5 check Network
capture that Knight captures and now
King to e6 Bishop captures Knight
captures and it seems like this is
losing a piece since the queen is
attacked but this was actually caranas
idea all along Queen captures on g6
check given up d6 not d5 Knight King
captures on e5 and rope to East once
check and this is a beautiful position
now Napo has a choice you can either
play King to f4 this is the only move
with the king or he can block 92 if he
went King to f4 this actually leads to a
very quick checkmate g3 check King f3
and Queen to h5 checkmate so after rook
to e1 check he had to play Knight to e2
and now comes King to f1 attacking the
pin peace with the King oh yeah King to
d4 rook captures and E 5 so Caruana is
up a pawn but doesn't really matter the
the real strength is Nepos skiing on d4
and this is again completely winning but
both players are very very long time and
you know you have to play precise moves
Queen g3 g4 was played between to e3
check King e5 came to g1 now not long
any back bank back rank ideas so King to
h2 will always be an option Queen
captures on b3 now Queen to g5 check
King goes east six Queen g6 check in d7
and now rope to d2 we have h4 sort of
not allowing the Queen to capture it
immediately Queen to a5 check ER king c6
Queen to f6 check king c5 Queen to d4
check and King to c6 now Queen back to
f6 check king c5 and twin captures on h4
just making sure you know you're always
up upon rock to b7
Queen to d8 rock the b6 Queen to c7
check rock to c6 Queen to a5 check King
goes back Queen to d8 check King goes
back to c5 and now h4 III now but Queen
to e7 check King goes to b5 now Queen to
d7 check rope has the block if you play
any move with the King then you lose the
rook if you play unless you play king c5
but then you just lose the Queen
straight up
so after up to b6 rook captures on d5
would check King to c4 and now comes the
finisher Queen to f7 he captures an f2
King captures an f2 and in this position
neppo didn't yet resigned but there
isn't a good move here for black he
played the Queen to be to check and not
simply rook to d2 check and you lose the
Queen there is nothing to play here king
c3 simply capture capture and King g3
and queen and two points against the
rook is too easy to play there was a
maneuver neppo could have gone for for
example after this he captures on f2 and
the King captures an f2 he could have
went for this annoying rock to f6 line
but after Queen captures on f6
Queen c2 check and King g3 now capturing
again its Queen and two points against
the Queen maybe in some crazy universe
you could maybe create some
masterpiece draw from this position but
but very unlikely so yeah after this he
captures an f2 King captures and a rock
to d2 check young upon Miyaichi resigned
the game and Fabiano Caruana is the
winner of the London
classic 2017 so that's the game this
this is the game from the tiebreaks
round 4 I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Mark Gami for a
contribution to my channel thanks a lot
I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here I will make both of
them also games from the London chess
classic thank you all for watching and I
will see you soon